hi I'm Eric Voss and us the new horror
film from get out director Jordan Peele
these quite a bit unexplained not just
stately Cooper clearing a lot of minds
Addison's shiny into film nerds thirty
years later and claim it's really about
the moon-landing but what seems like a
socially conscious home invasion story
that then makes us feel like that older
sister and bolder guys I'm gonna explain
what's happening in us the ending the
deeper meaning some secrets that you
might missed
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
movie yet you dummy and clicked on this
without seeing us you deserve to be
killed by your double ok let's start
with the main question you might be
wondering about what exactly are these
tethers the tethers are part of a secret
government project in which Americans
were given doubles who live in
underground tunnels and mirror their
actions the tethers share a soul with
their surface selves and they control
their service selves movement like
puppets and the tethers survive by
eating rabbits that are caged down in
these tunnels now this project was
abandoned and I can't imagine why people
puppet Ian sounds like a slam dunk use
of public resources and one of these
abandoned mole people red Lupita Nyong'o
mobilize the other tethers into an
uprising attacking their surface world
doppelgangers this happens with the
Wilsons the main family as well as the
Tyler's and all over the country these
tethers all wear uniform red jumpsuits
one leather glove and they use golden
scissors now it's never explained why or
even how this coordination happened but
if you're able to just let go of the
practicality and logic of this uprising
and instead see it as more of a symbolic
statement that it was intended to be
these scissors are symmetrical and they
reflect both the literal and
metaphorical severance between the
tethers and their surface selves in the
final minutes of the movie we learned
that red is actually the real surface
world Adelaide in Adelaide we knew
throughout this movie was actually fake
the whole time when Adelaide was a young
girl she wandered into this house of
mirrors and there she met red her
underground mole person doppelgangers
Heather red choked Adelaide and then
swapped places with her and throughout
the movie there are actually a bunch of
clues that were dropped hinting that the
Adelaide we were seeing was actually a
mole person like in flashbacks that take
place after the incident at the
boardwalk young fake Adelaide never
spoke she required therapy and that's
tethers don't use their words they
communicate with grunts and clicks and
hand signals and later when adults fake
a delay tells Kitty that she isn't good
at talking that's the real reason why
also notice that when she teaches her
son to snap to the song she snaps off
rhythm with the beat of the music so
she's not normal and that's also why
this fake Adelaide peaked at ballet at
age 14 that was the precise moment the
real Adelaide danced brilliantly down
the tunnels and won the admiration of
the others Heather's fake Adelaide up on
the surface was never on rhythm in the
daughters hora brings up the conspiracy
theory that the government puts fluoride
in the water to control us which the
family ignores at the time because while
there is fluoride and a lot of public
water it's actually good for our teeth
the idea that it's used for mind control
is a false conspiracy theory I told them
no give me back my son but fake
Adelaide's reaction to this conspiracy
is a bit more shifty-eyed because while
fluoride mind-control is a false
conspiracy this fictional world totally
is controlled by government experiments
they cattle a doll so nibbles red
strawberries and those nipples are
really weird very reminiscent of the way
Alison believes character eat Froot
Loops and get out just a big red flag
and when we meet read the real Adelaide
she speaks with a croak a mix of damage
to her windpipe and probably rarely ever
using her speaking voice down in the
tunnels during their confrontation at
the end of the movie real Adelaide read
mostly dominates her doppelganger using
her ballet level footwork to sidestep
fake Adelaide and throw her further off
rhythm really it's mostly through luck
that fake Adelaide manages to kill red
and escape with her son Jason now as
Redd spends her life orchestrating her
revenge plot she fixated on the shreds
of surface world culture that she still
had with her including her hands across
America shirt the movie actually opens
with a TV promo for hands across America
and the tethers creepily recreate the
stunt as they take over so what is the
deal with Hands Across America Hands
Across America was a nationwide charity
event in 1986 basically you pay 10 bucks
to join a simultaneous human chain from
coast to coast lots of celebrities
participated Michael Jackson and Bill
Cosby they were just holding hands right
the reason peel featured Hands Across
America in this movie is that us is a
uniquely American story even a title
can also be interpreted as us red tells
the family we're Americans and at one
point fake Adelaide suggests fleeing to
Mexico so Reds plan was to brand her
uprising with the most American image
she could think of the biggest thing on
TV before she went underground using her
hands across America's shirt as a kind
of banner or flag for their movement
also the lyrics of the Hands Across
America theme song might reflect the
relationship between these Americans and
their symmetrical mirror image tethers
[Music]
but joining this political imagery is a
recurring biblical reference Jeremiah
11:11 this Bible verse goes as follows
thus says the Lord behold I am bringing
disaster on them which they will not be
able to escape though they will cry to
me yet I will not listen to them you
might recognize this verse from the
famous quote in the Watchmen spoken by
the character rorschach whose sigil
actually reflects the recurring symmetry
of us and its inkblot marketing campaign
the book of jeremiah features the wrath
of God as he judges his people for their
pagan worship and false idols in Babylon
and his quote evokes a day of reckoning
similar to what the surface-level
America of us experiences 11:11 shows up
all over this movie of course on the
homeless man sign but also
one-one-one-one is the number of the
ambulance that he's loaded into the
score of the game on TV that Gabe
watches is 11 to 11 and of course 11:11
is on the clock and Jason's room and if
you look at this number visually it's
also symmetrical 11:11 in the four ones
reflect the four tether family members
in the driveway and this chain of ones
also reflects the chain of tethers and
hands across america 2.0 if you combine
all of this it gets us to Jordan peels
deeper meaning of this movie one
interesting detail in the final image is
that the human chain of the tethers goes
over rugged terrain unbroken
in the actual hands across america 1986
there were a ton of gaps this country's
topography would make this nearly
impossible to pull off so I think this
final image implies a cynical view of
American society to be American in this
movie is to be a soulless drone going
through the motions chasing false idols
like the people of Babylon did but these
false idols are things like material
wealth alcoholism technology Peale has
said in interviews that the movie is
about facing our demons that maybe
instead of seen ourselves as the good
guys in fearing the other that may be
the monster that we all need to look at
is our own faces and maybe the evil is
us and yeah by suggesting that these
teather mole people are victorious over
the surface world suggest that those
monsters are superior to us in more
deserving of inheriting this earth the
adelaid who wins is the one born as a
tether the one who stole someone else's
life and she might not be the only one
who did this because
is the Sun hiding in the final scene as
the family drives away Jason side eyes
his mom perhaps suspecting that she's
actually fake Adelaide from when he was
hiding in the locker during their
confrontation but Jason ultimately
shrugs it off and lowers his Chewbacca
mask because I think the real twist of
this movie is that Jason is also his
tether swapped with his real self look
at the evidence Jason's an odd kid he is
weird eating habits like fake Adelaide
does growing up having to gobble down
caged rabbits will do quite a number to
your appetite and notice how fake
Adelaide and Jason both snap and sync
with each other but both are off rhythm
to the song because neither of them
truly belong in this surface world when
they arrive at the vacation house Jason
runs off to find his old magic tricks
Parker that was left there from a past
summer but he can't remember how to use
it meanwhile it's his doppelganger who
has burned scars on his face perhaps
that was the real Jason a pyromaniac
whose magic trick went awry and it was
his tether who swapped with him and
wouldn't know how to use his magic trick
that could be why it's Jason who
recognizes this doppelganger family and
why red doesn't kill him when she
kidnaps him because this would be the
son that she would have given birth to
fake Jason before he swapped with the
real Jason burn scars but to me the
biggest evidence is when those girls
cartwheel on his sand castle on the
beach they asked if it was a sand castle
and Jason says that he was actually
digging sand tunnels yeah mole person
confirmed my question for you guys is do
you think us is scarier without
explaining how this mole person
uprising worked or would you have
preferred more of the backstory to be
spelled out comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on instagram and
twitter at EI vas and subscribe the new
rock stars for more in-depth analyses of
your favorite movies thank you for
watching and you know isn't it great
that the world of us is just a fictional
nightmare rather than a real one
[Laughter]
[Music]